l'opération à un bien joli nom le love
challenge en 2016 un petit groupe d'amis
à semer une graine
en lançant cette initiative du jus
l'édifice cuit pour les sans abri depuis
l'opération a grandi en générosité et
les participants prennent plaisir à
diversifier leurs cadeaux j'ai appris
qu'il y avait ce groupe ce matin donc je
me suis greffé quand j'ai vu au niveau
de la liste parce que c'était quand même
bien fait ce qu'ils avaient je me suis
dit bon j'ai apporté quelque chose de
différent et j'ai pensé au chocolat
parce qu'au départ je voulais faire des
choses qui sont déjà sur la liste mais
ça fait partie aussi de l'esprit de noël
le chocolat et le pont vers quoi
aujourd'hui on a un plat chaud chaque
fois et un lot avec des sandwichs des
compotes
on essaie de mettre les choses équilibré
donc descendu j'ai des compotes des
biscuits secs alors qu'ils puissent
avoir des d'arrêt pour la semaine à
venir
d'une année à l'autre les bénévoles
change certains sdf aussi mais willy
plombier de métier prend toujours son
rôle très à coeur
et bien aujourd'hui l'ofia langer à 3,1
et on avoue j'ai voulu ajouter aux
petits plus vers la distribution
m'habillant au père noël
est-ce qu'on se sent différent
ben oui ce matin père noël va distribuer
ses cadeaux une cinquantaine de sans
abri visiblement certains sont très
surpris
vous l'avez pas le moment de mourir
et puis on sera toujours pendant
quelques heures les bénévoles vont
suivre le père noël à vélo dans les
moindres ruelles de la capitale
personne ne doit être oublié faisons
cette distribution dans le cadre pouvoir
en soutenant d'être avec vous donc se
voit pas soit bénie nous avions filmé
jules il y a deux ans il dormait sous un
pont de la rocade
la junior avec marc adhérents n'ont pas
moi voici un repas jour de noël cauchon
pois d'angole des chocolats des gâteaux
quelques affaires de toilette
les bénévoles sont comblés lorsqu'un
sans abri acceptent leur présent mais
certaines personnes refuseront tout
contact
ça ça m'embête de les voir là surtout
quand j'essaie de faire ce geste et y en
a qui refusent donc moi j'essaie
toujours de d'avoir notamment une
discussion avec elle de façon pour
pouvoir laisser diot et d'accepter tout
ce petit par otage mais c'est pas c'est
pas toujours évident donc on ne force
pas là mais non plus le love challenge
est plus généreux que le père noël
il passe en ville toute l'année chaque
dernier dimanche du mois
ainsi les volontaires seront toujours là
dimanche prochain quel que soit le temps
pour porter un repas chauds aux oubliés
de la vie